[Musique]
salut je m'appelle moritz timmerman j'ai
17 ans et ça là c'est ma génération la
génération z
la technologie nous offre des
possibilités infinies
et qu'est-ce qu'on en fait des feuilles
soient franchement qu'est ce qui te fait
croire que toi tu vas réussir mieux que
les autres
tous les gens qui ont réussi étaient des
nerd avant l'heure d'aujourd'hui big
boss demain et c'est quoi le plan
comment vendre de la drogue sur internet
bout alors ça c'est l'idée la plus
criminelle que tu aies jamais eu il
paraît qu'on vend dès 16 ans j'étais
l'ecstasy si on se lançait que ça marche
on pourra faire tout ce qu'on veut
première règle du choc il est interdit
de parler du charme fight club jamais vu
bon combien tu en veux tout le stock
vingt-et-une commandant trois jours ça
diraient qu'on aille faire un peu la
fête ce soir
ça y est il est là le bon moment tu veux
quoi et casser la gueule c'est pas
exclue d'accord alors tu peux entrer
j'ai pas donner le reste de l'argent aux
divers il est où le fric je vous
donnerai bientôt free qui promet une
mauvaise réponse je vous le donne tout
de suite ça à part dont c'était la bonne
réponse
si si c'est bien ce qui s'est passé